[Música]
y como lo avanzamos venimos hablando del
polémico lenguaje inclusivo la variación
morfológica y sintáctica del español que
busca dar cabida a otras identidades de
género más allá de hombres y mujeres
esto ha generado un fuerte rechazo de
los expertos en la lengua el lenguaje se
define como poderoso dinámico y para
muchos es sinónimo de la forma en la que
nosotros vemos el mundo las palabras son
las bases para nuestra conexión con
otros con nuestro entorno y también con
nuestra propia identidad para los
activistas de la comunidad lgtb más
identificarnos en nuestros propios
términos y ser reconocidos o con
palabras inclusivas forma parte de esta
democratización del lenguaje y también
del orgullo de ser quiénes somos pero
para los expertos en la lengua para
algunos eso se trata de algún necesario
y que algunos también lo catalogan como
la destrucción del español en nuestro
caso para ellos ya me acompaña en el
estudio de nuestra segunda invitada del
día ella es dani haro belmont directora
ejecutiva de la fundación cat grupo de
acción y apoyo de las personas trans
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo american france24
gracias a ustedes por la invitación y
por interesarse también en
ponerse ot también en público y
conocimiento de las personas pues
hablemos entonces del lenguaje inclusivo
pues empecé con la primera con esta
pregunta que lo va a hacer con nuestro
primer invitado y se lago también usted
destrucción de la lengua o lucha por la
igualdad yo siento que es una lucha por
la igualdad porque es que igual la
lengua está construida también para
comunicar lo que somos como
representamos también la cultura y esta
transformación cultural implica también
un reconocimiento de derechos ahí lo que
estamos hablando no es solamente cómo se
transforma el lenguaje sino cómo hacemos
las personas también para que el derecho
de la identidad y el autorreconocimiento
de otras identidades y otras personas
también tenga una validez cuando lo
hablamos en público o en espacios mucho
más amplios el lenguaje inclusivo le
apunta justamente esa transformación
dane
como es el lenguaje lo como lo conocemos
ahora le parece que es incluso
excluyente yo siento que está formado
sobre unas bases demasiado patriarcales
y machistas sobre la lectura general o
sea seguimos pensando que hablar
solamente masculino no es invisibilizar
las figuras femeninas dentro del
lenguaje pero históricamente hemos visto
que cuando las cosas no se nombran como
son y adquieren una serie de barreras
para acceder a los mismos derechos
cuando hablamos por ejemplo de nuevas
formas o transformaciones del lenguaje
no estamos hablando de algo que
solamente pase con el lenguaje inclusivo
el lenguaje no sexista pasa con todo
ahorita como los mencionados por ejemplo
incluso terminología que hemos adaptado
y que hemos aprendido en el último año y
medio que tiene que ver con el coi 19 de
las enfermedades el contagio eso también
tiene que ver con la adaptación y la
transformación porque es que hemos
tenido también que adaptarnos y
transformar justamente la forma como nos
relacionamos con la cultura y con lo que
nos pasa así como cambiamos y aprendimos
cosas nuevas para hablar del coi 19
también lo podemos hacer para aprender y
reconocer las identidades de las
personas no binarias o personas trans
que no se sienten dentro de este binario
y lo masculino y lo femenino dane
estamos a su parecer en la evolución
digamos o empezando a evolucionar ya
incluir en nuestro lenguaje en nuevos
términos como lo ves yo siento que todo
el tiempo el lenguaje está en evolución
o sea cuando lo miramos también en
perspectiva utilizar por ejemplo
términos como google buscar tuitear o
las adaptaciones y las correcciones que
hace la misma academia la lengua
española implican un avance del
reconocimiento no solamente de cómo
hablamos las personas sino también de
qué estamos hablando ahí es importante
reconocer que las identidades trans y no
binarias también merecen ese tipo de
reconocimiento y siento que la
transformación no es tan radical no le
pedimos a todas las personas que lo
hagan todo el tiempo no le pedimos sino
que respeten a las personas que quieren
ser enunciadas de esa manera digamos
como si nos puede dar ejemplos no de
cómo puede ser este lenguaje inclusivo
para referirse a una persona en no
binaria antes de ustedes estábamos con
nuestro primer invitado también y nos
hablaba sobre algunos ejemplos de hablar
también de ver la humanidad como pues
una zona y no simplemente como un
masculino femenino de estos desde su
perspectiva como lo ven como nos puede
explicar o poner ejemplos no reales para
entender un poco más digamos lo
principal para hablar del lenguaje
inclusivo es también entender que no
toda la figura a la que nos estamos
refiriendo es una figura masculina por
ejemplo cuando hablamos de todos los
hombres
en el mundo estamos hablando
particularmente de una figura masculina
en el mundo cuando hablamos de todas las
personas en el mundo ahí ya estamos
hablando del lenguaje inclusivo porque
no estamos reconociendo solamente la
figura del hombre en el mundo sino
también de las mujeres de las personas
trans de las personas no binarias no
todo tiene que ver con poner una al
final o poner un les antes o decir todos
todas y todas tienen que ver también con
cómo nos estamos pensando antes lo que
vamos a anunciar si decimos por ejemplo
todas las personas que estudian biología
entendemos que son profesionales o
personas que se están dedicando también
a esta labor no es necesario decir
solamente como todos los biólogos en el
mundo a eso nos referimos un poco cuando
hablamos del lenguaje inclusivo a
reconocer las ciencias pero también a
veces centralizar esta figura de lo
masculino como sobre lo único a lo que
podemos hacer referencia y lo único
sobre lo que podemos trabajar porque
esto también tiene que ver con una lucha
social y política
eso le quería preguntar cómo hacen
ustedes entonces para concientizar a las
personas y no sé si también a los
políticos desde su fundación en
específicamente desde la fundación gas
generamos espacios seguros para las
personas con experiencias de vida trans
y no binarias que no encuentran
justamente estos espacios de
reconocimiento a partir de allí
empezamos a generar espacios de apoyo
para las personas y empezamos a generar
una serie de estrategias de
reconocimiento de incidencia política
para impactar también no solamente en el
territorio nacional sino también a
través de la articulación con otras
organizaciones a nivel internacional lo
que implica pensarse como una persona
trans en américa latina'
en argentina el presidente el gobierno
presidente alberto fernández ya incluyó
no en el documento de identidad poner
poder poner una equis o no identificarse
es ciertamente con algún género femenino
o masculino ustedes aquí en colombia por
ejemplo quieren hacer una iniciativa
como ésta o ya está esta iniciativa
la semana pasada se hizo más público
pero esto era un caso que había ocurrido
a inicios de año
mike fue una persona trans no binaria
que logró poner por primera vez en
colombia a través de una serie de
derechos de peticiones y tutelas en su
cédula en la categoría no femenino
masculino sino una t que representaba
trans esto implica también una
transformación y una mirada distinta en
cosas tan pequeñas como nos pensamos la
salud cómo nos pensamos la educación
cómo nos pensamos la edad de pensión
para las personas porque implica dejar
de pensar nos en el binario solamente la
existencia de lo masculino y lo femenino
y empezar a apostarle a qué es lo que
realmente nos interesa si nos interesa
clasificar a las personas por su sexo de
nacimiento si vamos a hacer una
taxonomía completa y vamos a averiguar
le todo el pasado a las personas o
queremos que se pensionen a una u otra
en razón a las dificultades barreras de
acceso o experiencias de vida que han
tenido dale ya tenemos 30 segundos para
terminar esa entrevista su conclusión
entonces en torno a este lenguaje
inclusivo cuál que es que es cuál es el
mensaje que quiere dar yo creo que sobre
todo es muy sencillo practicarlo es muy
sencillo hacerlo y sobre todo el valor
que tienen el reconocimiento y la
transformación que tiene el aceptar la
identidad de otras personas es increíble
esa transformación en colectivos
solamente es posible si entre todos nos
acompañamos pues ane gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros esta
mañana de jueves en directo américa en
franza 24 gracias a ustedes por la
invitación estábamos conversando con
dante haro belmont directora ejecutiva
de la fundación cat grupo de acción y
apoyo a personas trans